[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEANNA MULVIHILL: So I'm
going to go do pig chores.
Hi piggies!
Four Legs Farm is my business.
I raise sheep, pigs and cows.
It's particularly
important this year
to build wallows for
the pigs, because we've
been in somewhat of a drought.
So right now they're
six months old.
So they're getting,
they're getting close.
They're getting
close to being bacon.
NARRATOR: This is
Leanna Mulvihill.
She raises livestock
for meat shares
on Four Legs Farm in
Hudson Valley, New York,
where she's actually
relatively new to farming.
Up until two years ago,
Leanna was on the path
to becoming an engineer.
But after college,
she realized that she
didn't want a desk job.
Instead, she wanted
to become a farmer.
However, that decision
didn't come lightly.
LEANNA MULVIHILL: I do not
come from a farming background.
It took me a while to have
the courage to be a farmer.
NARRATOR: It took
courage because there
are a number of
hurdles preventing
young people like Leanna
from taking the leap
to become a farmer.
Today only 6% of
farmers in the US
are under the age of 35, which
for the agricultural industry
is a problem.
SOPHIE ACKHOFF: We are
in a farming crisis
now, where our
farming population
is aging out and retiring.
And we need young people to
take on this role of growing
our nation's food, but they're
facing incredible challenges
in doing that, including
access to land, capital
credit, student loan debt.
Many young farmers
today are discovering
agriculture in college.
They're not growing
up in farm families.
And this debt that they've
accumulated from college
is preventing them
from getting started.
NARRATOR: Leanna
was fortunate enough
to qualify for a
unique loan forgiveness
program in New York, which
allowed her to pay off her debt
and kick start her business.
LEANNA MULVIHILL: Without
the loan forgiveness program,
financing the farm would
have been more challenging.
I'm very thankful
to be a part of it
and it definitely
cushioned my first couple
of years of farming.
NARRATOR: But the loan
forgiveness program
hasn't solved all
of her problems.
She still has to work another
job to make ends meet.
LEANNA MULVIHILL: Most of
the time I work 12 hour days.
And I can't really leave the
farm for more than a few hours.
I don't really take days off.
I always have to do chores.
And then I go to my job at
the National Young Farmer's
Coalition, which is also a
key piece of figuring out how
to make this work financially.
SOPHIE ACKHOFF:
Young farmers have
to be extremely creative to
make it in agriculture today,
whether that's
working several jobs
or finding land through a
land trust or a current land
owner who is willing to let
them use part of their land.
NARRATOR: The National
Young Farmer's Coalition
hopes to help young
farmers in that cause.
SOPHIE ACKHOFF: In
the next 25 years,
2/3 of farmer-owned
land in the US
will have transitioned
ownership.
If young farmers aren't
successful in taking
over this land,
it's possible we'll
start importing our
food from overseas.
This is a national
security issue.
We need farmers in the
United States growing
food for our country.
NARRATOR: Essentially
this means that the US
could become more and more
dependent on other countries
for food.
What the NYFC are
fighting for is
to give young people like
Leanna the financial support
to continue and sustain the
farming tradition in the US.
Until legislation to support
young farmers is realized,
folks have to do the
best with what they have.
For Leanna, this means
applying for grants
and renting, rather than
owning, land for her animals.
LEANNA MULVIHILL: So I move
the sheep every three days
to a new spot.
And as you can
see, they've eaten
a lot of the grass over there.
NARRATOR: One day Leanna hopes
to eventually own her own land
and expand her meat
share business.
LEANNA MULVIHILL: I love
getting to provide my community
with really healthy proteins.
It feels really
special that it's
like people I know that
are eating the meat.
Hopefully it makes
them healthier
and improves their
quality of life.
My life, my world revolves
around, being at the farm
and taking care of my animals.
I do get to work in
a beautiful place.
I do get to see
spectacular sunsets.
And I get to see-- see
the animals playing.
And it's definitely a privilege
to be able to be here at all.
And I try really hard not
to take it for granted
and to take pause and make
sure I'm drinking it all in.
NARRATOR: To hear more
about the farming crisis
and what NYFC are doing,
check this next episode out
on Seeker daily.
NARRATOR 2: Some
states have even
started offering student loan
forgiveness to new farmers,
adding to the current list
of forgivable occupations,
such as teaching
and law enforcement.
SOPHIE ACKHOFF: We believe
farmers can produce good
for their community,
steward the land
and feed their communities--
and at the same time,
be profitable businesses.
Thanks for watching and be sure
to subscribe to Seeker Stories
for new videos every week.